I'm a geek
we rank stuff
[Music]
I have finished the latest season of
Black Mirror reviews for that we're
going up in the break room of Geeks my
secondary Channel if you uh weren't
catching those but now it's time for me
to do something that I have not done in
a while and that is to give a full
ranking of all of Black Mirror every
episode including the specials now this
has been a while since I've done this as
I said last time I did this it was
before season five came out
so I've got two seasons plus the bander
snatch special to work in but even if
you remember the last time I did this
which
if you do bless you you've been around
for a while
even if that's the case don't assume you
know where everything's gonna land
because some of the things that were
already on the list have shifted
position as my own feelings have changed
and evolved with time not necessarily
that the work has gotten worse but you
know
for very visibly evident Reasons I'm not
the same person I was when I uh ranked
those things before
how will that affect the uh way things
shake out well
let's find out we got 28 of these to go
let's get to it
number 28. Beyond the Sea
yeah I'm actually kind of surprised that
this one ended up coming in at the
bottom and this might get some heat I
don't know feelings on this one seem to
be very mixed here's the short version
of why this one comes in at the bottom
for me I don't know what it's doing
and that's very rare for Black Mirror
generally I know what they're trying for
um and even sometimes they're trying for
nothing of substance and it's just
aiming to be fun we'll get to some
examples of that in a little bit but
this I don't I don't know what it's
actually doing and being as long as it
is and being shot and framed and
presented the way it is it really feels
like it thinks it's making a point I
don't know what that is and part of the
Fallout of me not knowing for sure what
it's doing is I don't even know how much
I should be criticizing like do I
criticize the ending for fridging the
major female character
and treating her as disposable and more
important for her death impacting the
male character or do I not criticize
that because the misogyny is part of
what is supposed to be going on like is
this a
deconstruction of massaging I don't know
like there's stuff that I don't like but
I didn't I don't even know if I can
criticize it rightfully because I don't
know what this one's doing I just don't
I don't know what point it's trying to
make I don't know what the intent of the
final uh scene is I just don't know what
it's doing
number 27
men against fire now this one I do get
and it's actually not even badly made
and honestly I probably rank this lower
than nearly anybody else if I were to
guess but the thing is ultimately this
is the episode of Black Mirror that I
feel is the most derivative
in that this plot line This twist
I've seen it done like very literally I
saw practically this exact same scenario
play out in the 90s version of The Outer
Limits and that might have been the
first time I saw it but it's a concept
that's older than that and I'm not
saying that to be like oh it's a ripple
off the thing is a lot of the ideas
presented in Black Mirror aren't
necessarily new or have never been done
before it's just they're usually
presented in a slightly different way or
with a slightly different way of
presenting it or like just being done at
a higher level of
um execution then the idea has been done
before none of that's really the case
here it's fine it's perfectly
serviceable but I've literally seen this
exact thing done already so
yeah
number 26
the Waldo moment this
um I guess a little bit like Beyond the
Sea doesn't quite pull together except
at least I think I know what this one's
trying to do whereas Beyond the Sea I
just I don't know what it's aiming for I
think I understand what the Waldo moment
is doing but the way that it is kind of
integrating the uh parody of the
political system as well as integrating
the idea of a piece of artwork getting
out of control and out of the hands of
the original artist who is not able to
properly maintain or control the way
that it is perceived by the public those
two ideas don't fully gel like I could
see how they would have and it's not
that far off I just feel like it needed
one or two more drafts like to really
solidify the the melding of its thematic
elements I've heard that it plays better
if you're from the UK and you're used to
the whole concept of joke candidates
because that is actually a thing over
there there but I'm fond of saying I can
only speak from the perspective I have
and from that perspective I don't quite
think this one pulls together
number 25
Maisie day this one people seem to
really dislike it's from the latest
season I actually think it's quite fun
now I alluded to an episode that like
really isn't trying to do anything other
than just be kind of fun this is that
one this thing does not have
particularly High Ambitions it
integrates a supernatural element that I
think threw a lot of people off it
wasn't the only episode to do so in that
season however it was one where the
supernatural element kind of came out of
nowhere whereas the other one which
we'll get to later in the list that one
presented it pretty much up front so it
at least gave you the time to adjust to
it whereas this kind of just dropped it
on you at a I don't know two-thirds
point or so but I still enjoy it I like
the energy of it I think the
performances are good it's not deep it's
not making all that much of a point but
I don't think it's trying to either and
so if I'm gonna compare this to
something like Beyond the Sea I'll take
something that aims low but just feels
like it's well executed and manages what
it tried to do to something that feels
like it was made with a higher
production value but just doesn't seem
to even know what it's doing or if it
does it doesn't know how to communicate
it properly I honestly at the end of the
day prefer something that knows what it
is and Nails what it's going for over
something that is ambitious and just
doesn't pull together
personal preference
number 24.
Shut Up and Dance
this one is almost
really good it falls apart because of
the final twist at least it does for me
so shut up and dance has this whole
thing with this young guy just getting
wrapped up with these trolls who have
gotten some information and some video
on him and it's just escalating he's
becoming worse and worse and worse and
worse as he's being goaded into this
succession of worse and worse things
ultimately culminating a situation where
he faces off I guess a complete stranger
and one of them's gonna have to kill the
other and the thing is the way it's
presented is way more interesting than
what the twist is because the way it's
presented it really feels like it's
about escalation it's about okay well
you do something to cover up for this
little thing but the thing that you did
to cover it up is bigger and then you
have to cover that up so that's bigger
and bigger and bigger and the spiral of
it and the fact that it initially seems
to start with something relatively
innocuous felt like it added to the
power so finding out with the final
twist like no actually this this young
guy is actually kind of terrible and
he's covering up something way worse I'm
like oh that actually takes the wind out
of the sails of this thing rather
considerably for me so it was quite good
up until the final twist which I
actually think undermines what was
working up to that point
number 23
Archangel uh just to be clear at this
point on I do think these are all good I
don't think any of these are are really
bad or like don't work or I may have
some criticisms but not as much as what
we've talked about up to now but from
here it is largely a matter of personal
preference because there's certainly
nothing wrong with Archangel I think it
approaches its ideas about helicopter
parenting pretty well
the issue for me is I just can't really
relate to it I never had a parent like
that I'm not a parent like that I
actually have never really known anyone
who has had a parent like that at least
in the time that I've known them so it's
the kind of parenting experience either
having a parent that is that level of
overprotective or feeling parental
instincts that are that degree of
overprotective I can't relate to it on
either end like I'm protective of my kid
don't get me wrong but I can't relate to
this woman and that's not to say that
she's like impossible to
um to relate to obviously other people
can and do just for me I I just can't
connect in on the scenario that's being
done it still seems pretty well executed
I just don't have a lot of attachment to
it
number 22.
smithereens
this one
is honestly largely buoyed by really
good performances because it's overall
point that is kind of making about
social media about the Detachment of
tech CEOs and the ways that this whole
thing can just cause
it's really toxic behavior and cause
things to spiral and spend out of
control and bring out the worst in
people
like it's solid and it works but it's
also just a little bit more
fatalistic nihilistic numerous I guess
then I really care for at this
particular point so I guess fine but
it's one it's one of the ones that I
have never watched the second time I've
never felt the need
number 21.
play test
this is one that actually it kind of
um I'll relate it to men against fire
this is not a super unique core concept
it's something I've seen done more than
a few times however it does do it better
than I've usually seen it done because
this idea of someone kind of losing
himself into this virtual reality game
situation by and large those things
don't work like I love David Cronenberg
but existence does not work for me at
all because it's very clear that David
Cronenberg does not understand games and
doesn't understand why people play games
he was using games to try and make some
other point but like the fact that I'm
watching this going nobody would ever
play this this is not how games work
just pulled me out of that story Here
Charlie Brooker with his background he
knows how games work he knows the inner
workings of games he knows how testing
works and so this is able to take an
idea that the core idea I've seen done
before but do it better by bringing in
actual knowledge because he knows what
he's talking about it's still not like
amazing or fantastic but it's just a
better execution of this idea than I've
usually seen
number 20.
metal head I used to have this one
ranked a fair bit higher I'm pretty sure
this uh is kind of a one that
exemplifies for me sort of how I've
changed over the years which is that the
uh the fatalistic nature of it and just
how
screwed everything is how dark this
actually is
I guess I just kind of moved past that
in general I think what at the time that
I saw this I was at the tail end of my
ability to appreciate this kind of
material that doesn't make it any worse
than it ever has been I actually think
the Stark black and white uh look of the
thing is quite good I I've seen some
people criticize the uh ending to us
that like all these people were after
were these freaking stuffed bears for a
kid that's dying anyways and I've seen
some people criticize that like on the
basis of why would people risk their
life so this I'm like that's the point
that's how screwed the entire world is
that human life is means so little that
you might as well risk it just to bring
a smile to the face of a Dying child
because what the hell else are you gonna
do I actually think it is well executed
and that twist makes sense I actually
like the way the dogs are done I like
how they're built for efficiency and
simplicity and they're not particularly
intimidating but dang are they deadly
it's just a level of Doom and Gloom that
I I just don't connect with at this
point the way that I used to it
in though
number 19.
bandersnatch this was a weird one to
figure out where to put it because like
how do you rank this one how do you
evaluate it do you evaluate it as a
narrative if so
how
do you evaluate it on how your narrative
experience was it on your first time
viewing do you evaluate it on if you
went back and saw every possible
variation do you evaluate what you think
is the best one all of them how much do
you take the interaction into account
like there's a lot to factor into this
this is I think a very cool experiment
it's also something I don't think needs
to happen ever again not with black
mirror or indeed anything else but the
way that it fits together the way that
it kind of breaks its own reality here
and there it's
it's well done for what it is what it is
trying to be I think it actually hits it
pretty well
it is one of those things that once I
saw every alternate version I'm like I
have no reason to ever watch this ever
again but it's still kind of cool every
now and then to look at the flow chart
of the options and to see the different
ways that it can go like it's the kind
of thing that's very easy to admire but
I don't really need to go back to
number 18. White Bear
this one for me is kind of just mid on
the scale of Black Mirror understanding
that mid Black Mirror is high-end for
most other things
one thing I really appreciate about I
appreciate about this one is the
intensity of the Dilemma the moral
dilemma at the heart of this given what
it was she did that most people who
would agree is terrible the kind of gut
visceral reaction I'll let people have
what should happen to someone who did
that but then realizing and thinking
about the reality of what's actually
being done to her and realizing that
because of the uh the memory loss
involved in the way that they are
tormenting her
she's not the same person as the one who
did this awful thing
but at the same time like well would she
still be capable of being that person
can she carry the sins for that person
is it still deserved and I have my own
opinions on that for my money it is a
miscarriage of justice but I remember
the comments when I did my review on
that they were heated on both sides
people were really really firm on which
they thought was the correct side of
that moral dilemma to be on and the fact
that it was that big a split and that
clearer split and thankfully this was
back in the days where people would
vocalize their opinions but not
necessarily feel the need to attack
those who disagreed with them happened
sometimes it didn't happen as much at
least not on my channel in my comments
probably because I was masculine
presenting at the time so I didn't have
as many argumentative who just
showed up trying to start fights but
anyways
just seeing how much of a divide this
one causes to me says that it
accomplished what it went for very well
but again like it's Bleak it's real
Bleak and I know a lot of people kind of
consider that to be a staple of Black
Mirror and to an extent sure but
sometimes things are just slightly on
the edge of being a little bit too Bleak
for me this is this is right on the edge
of that
number 17.
White Christmas this is another one that
I know that I ranked much higher I think
largely because of the emotional impact
of the uh The Last Story involved you
know with the with the guy and the young
kid that he thought was his
that thing hit me real hard and that
broke me in a lot of ways it broke me in
a way that the only other thing that I
can think of off the top you know not
necessarily the only other thing that
did it but the only other thing off the
top of my head that broke me to that
extent was uh Under the Skin the beach
uh scenes if you've seen it then you
know and if you haven't seen it I'm not
gonna explain it to you but like it
broke me in a similar way and for a
similar reason
um the thing was
the rest of it didn't leave a lot of
lasting impact like that particular
aspect of it that hit and that landed
and that hurt
it hurt a lot
but
the rest of it is just kind of there
like it's fine it's functional I kind of
remember it
but when all of its weight was just in
that one moment and it's a moment that I
don't care to read revisit or relive
I can acknowledge his power while also
going
maybe the maybe I was buoying up the
rest of it on the strength of that alone
a little bit last time I did this
ranking
number 16.
crocodile does some similar stuff to
White Christmas and uh it it hurt me in
a similar way though not as bad but also
gives an overall uh package that the
surrounding elements also stuck with me
more so that's kind of why it edged up
over white Christmas for me it's
um managing to tackle or at least hit
some of the same nerves for me as a
viewer but the overall conception and
nature of it in the ins and outs of the
tech involved and the nature of just
this woman and the
extent
to which she lets
this technology dictate how far she
takes something
it's a story overall that is lasted in
my brain more than the story of White
Christmas did so yeah I gotta give this
one the slight Edge over
number 15.
lock Henry so this is from the latest
season this is the one dealing with sort
of true crime documentaries and this one
as well as another one that we'll get to
in a little bit I think is largely made
by the very end by its closing moments
that make it clear what it is it's
actually doing because yes it's taking
apart The Sensational nature of these
kinds of documentaries uh yes it is sort
of looking at the way that trying to
look at
um you know these kinds of horrible
events through the lens of these kinds
of presentations is distancing and then
having it smack you in the face when you
realize you can't actually distance
yourself from this because of what goes
on with one of the characters and then
at the very end
just leaving him sitting in that hotel
room by himself looking at the suicide
note from his mother and just realizing
you know what
no matter what you made this into no
matter what it was no matter what
praise Awards whatever
ultimately you just have to sit here
with your trauma
you can turn your trauma into art you
can turn it into schlock you can do
something with it but it's still just
trauma
and you're still stuck with it
that's very black mirror and I like that
number 14.
black Museum this is one that's gone up
in my estimation I remember last time
that I did this list I kind of knocked
it for feeling not quite so much like
Black Mirror feeling a little bit more
like Tales from the Crypt in terms of
its overall tone and presentation but
honestly I kind of like it for that now
I like kind of like it for that
Divergence and like it has its most uh
campy over-the-top story as its first of
the three stories and it it delves in a
little bit deeper with each subsequent
one and the ending for the framing story
actually ends up being quite cathartic
which I actually really love when uh
Black Mirror does catharsis it doesn't
do it a ton but when it does ah makes me
really happy and this this is one of the
more cathartic finales for an episode of
Black Mirror that I would say is out
there at all so this this one I like it
number 13.
Rachel Jack and Ashley too yeah
I like the one with Miley Cyrus I don't
know what to tell you I don't know if it
was a Miley Cyrus backlash that had
people kind of dunking on this one when
it came out I think it's quite good I
think the dynamic between the siblings
is good I think the way in which it
examines how
um you know people who are you know
managers agents
um record Executives whatever it is you
know who sort of own the image and the
work of a pop star or celebrity or
whatever and sort of leave the human
being behind as much as they can get
away with doing through the lens of how
this one does it with the with the
little Ashley 2 robot and all that I I
think it's really clever with Amy I
think it's well pulled together and I
just think it works I think it works I
think it's fun
and I think especially in the wake of
something like free Brittany which
happened after this aired
I think
um people might be uh due to reassess
this one
number 12.
national anthem the very first episode
and this is the other one like Locke
Henry that the very end is what makes it
so the thing is the very end of this
because you know we have dealt with
um this weird Twisted assignment that
this guy sort of gives to the Prime
Minister will he do it won't he he does
it we see the impact and then ultimately
we also see that the world
moves on like people are amused
entertained disgusted but then also
they get over it
but then he has to go home
and his wife's there
and she can't look at them
the internet
has a long memory but a short attention
span
the internet never forgets what you did
but it will stop paying attention to you
pretty quickly if you give it if you
don't keep giving a reason to pay
attention to you
your wife is still there dude
she still has to see you every day
she can't just move on
and that really nails that episode and
also I always appreciate this one just
as a boldness of um sort of intent and
purpose like I've seen some people
suggest oh you shouldn't watch the first
episode first I actually think you
should because I to my way of viewing it
the reason this first episode is like
this is because it's basically saying
look we're not saying this is what every
episode will be like but if you can't
handle this you shouldn't be here you
should just leave
I just admire that
number 11.
Joan is awful the first episode of the
latest season
and I just had a good time with this I
just thought the performances were a lot
of fun clearly the actors involved
especially some of the bigger names they
got are having an absolute blast in this
one and that fun is infectious and it is
kind of a uh a lighter it's not a
particularly deep uh dive into the
ethics or the technology uh that's at
Play It's one of sort of the more
surface level as far as that goes but
it's just a lot of fun to see this thing
unravel and realize the nature of it and
just watch it all play out and to see
these actors showing up and putting in
the work in the parts that they've got
it's
fun Black Mirror is not always fun but
you know what I like it when it's fun it
does fun well this is fun
number 10
hated in the nation
this one's this one's really interesting
because the the technology that or at
least one of the aspects of the
technology in it the whole uh artificial
bees thing is weird and like sort of one
of the more like what but the actual
ethical and moral and thematic heart of
this
of Internet Hate mobs of piling on
and of removing the context
of why people do it of how they justify
it and why they think it's okay
oh I'm just doing this because that
person does deserve what they're getting
I'm just doing it to be part of the
moment and part of this Zeitgeist that's
going on I'm just doing it because I'm
bored
it doesn't matter
still not okay
and as far as this episode is concerned
you'll be judged the same regardless of
your reason whether you know you don't
have a good reason for doing it or
whether you have lied to yourself and
think that you do
you will be judged the same
this is really good
number nine
hang the DJ
this was the first quote unquote happy
ending episode of Black Mirror that I
personally saw because if you weren't
aware I actually watched season four
first because it's an anthology you can
watch it out of order and then I went
back and watched uh and watched the
other ones but
I like the way that this kind of
snowballs and sort of the the way that
it makes light uh and also like
acknowledges the depths of the
frustration and pain of just trying to
connect with people just trying to find
something that works
I don't put it uh higher than this
person because like and so
a little bit like this is going to be a
weird one to compare to but a little bit
like Shut Up and Dance I kind of like
what I thought was going on a little
more than what actually is because what
I thought was going on was that you know
all of these uh relationships that these
people are being put in and you know
sometimes they're incredibly short
sometimes they last for ages even though
these people cannot stand each other
what I thought it was gonna do was
basically acknowledge the
fact that an algorithm like that is only
cared about the end results and it
doesn't really care if you enjoy the
process that it will put you through
hell if it can get you to the end result
that you asked uh it to give you it
doesn't care if you enjoy how it got
there and then the end result that it's
you know sort of just running these
simulations over and over and over again
it's
it's works I just don't find it quite as
interesting but
having kind of gotten over that and
accepting it for what it is as opposed
to kind of what I almost would have
preferred it to be
um I do still like it and it's by the
end it's just heartwarming
number eight
demon 79 last episode of the most recent
season
this one I like the more I think about
it I actually when I first finished
watching it I didn't think I was gonna
put it this high on the list but you
know what the more I think about it
how early it introduces Supernatural
elements the amazing chemistry between
its leads Nida and Goff and the how well
it embodies just
how things were turning in a really
nasty Direction in places like the UK in
79 on the verge of the Thatcher era of
politics
who it really captures a moment in time
that I can't claim to its accuracy I
wasn't alive and I didn't live there but
it feels very authentic and it feels
like it gives Credence to a perspective
that I'm certainly more interested in if
you're going to show me that time uh
that point in time then I think we get
more commonly and it manages to do an
end of the world story that doesn't piss
me off and if you've been watching my
channel for a while you know ending the
world or destroying entire planets it
tends to piss me off it doesn't here
it works I go into more detail as to why
in my review of this episode but suffice
to say it's rare
for something to be able to end with a
nuclear Holocaust but two two characters
joining hand in hand to walk into
literal Oblivion and I've got a big
smile on my face but here we are
number seven
nosedive this one's gone up in my
estimation largely just because I've
kind of gotten over my discomfort of the
middle so how do I want to put this I
always felt that the beginning and the
ending were brilliant
the way in the beginning that social
media tugs on you
adjust your expectations like speaking
of someone who does this as my living
who like watches the view numbers
watches the moderates my comments like I
do all this stuff myself I literally
have a ticker on my on my channel for my
subscriber count which is part of how I
value my worth and I know that's not
healthy but I do it anyway boy the front
end Hit me hard and then the tail end
the ending of the is really cathartic
and I would argue counts as a happy
ending by Black Mirror standards I
really love the ending in that jail it's
so good the middle was hard for me
especially the stuff at the wedding
because it's cringe inducing and I'm not
good with cringe now it helps that it's
not cringe humor
you're meant to feel bad for her like
maybe you laugh a little but you're not
meant to point and laugh
you're meant to understand how horrible
she feels through all of this
and I did and it made me uncomfortable
and that's hasn't really stopped ever
being the case but I have gone to a
point where I'm like
this is necessary to get to the ending
so I'm more forgiving of it now than uh
than I was previously
and when you start this good and you end
this good
in the middle may be rough but it is
what it should be in order to get you
that ending yeah no that's a full
package
number six
the entire history of you
I think this one stands as a very pure
examination of
what if this technology was real because
it really does feel like an examination
of okay technologically we could do this
what would it do to us
would it be good for us because to put
it in short uh humans don't have Perfect
Memory they don't have perfect recall
and there's probably good reason for
that
at this point for the kind of social
animals that we are
what would we do what will we be like if
we could
just roll our life experience back and
re-examine
every little moment every little tone of
voice
every little glance
and overthink it depending on the kind
of person you are that's a real
unhealthy spiral
and I think this examines
how unhealthy that spiral is very
very well
because if you've ever been the kind of
person who whether you wanted to or not
has moments in your head that you can't
stop replaying or you can't stop
rethinking through or you can't keep
yourself from over analyzing
boy does this one hit hard
number five
be right back
this is a really good examination of
grief
grief is a tough thing to do justice to
in a format like this
because usually to properly examine
grief you really need a good amount of
time spent with the thing that is lost
as well as the person who has lost it
and there isn't the time for that here
so it examines grief in a very specific
way and again sort of extrapolating out
from current technology
so in the way that after someone is gone
you can still look
at their social media posts
and remember them as they presented
themselves to the world that becomes
embodied
in this Recreation of the man she lost
but he's also incomplete
because we don't share our entire selves
on social media
there are whole swaths of Who We Are
that never go on there
and eventually
he just becomes a reminder
of what she lost
not a proper Recreation of it but a
reminder
and he gets put up in the attic
with all the other things that she can't
look at anymore
but she also can't bring herself to get
rid of this is a really powerful
examination of grief and it's really
well done
number four
striking vipers I suspect I rank this
one a bit higher uh than some people do
I love this episode
I love it for a multitude of reasons
first of all again Charlie Booker
understands games thank goodness so the
um the integration of the video game
aspects and you know sort of having that
friend that you connected to and bond
with over games like that all feels very
genuine and very well done and then as
the sex aspect comes into it
the nature of being able to explore a
different part of who you are through an
avatar that's really well done
the nature of fidelity of exploration of
is this healthy and then then the final
resolution of how they seem to have
figured it out they've worked it out
they have a system it's not a
free-for-all
but it's no more secrets like as
somebody in polyamorous relationships
right now
yes yes it also has one of the most
brilliant cuts ever because I've talked
about like cringing stuff and like you
can see Anthony mackie's character
winding up to tell his wife
he takes a breath and then it cuts and
it jumps ahead we don't need to know we
don't need to watch How Deeply
uncomfortable that conversation would
have been we just jumped to where
they've worked it out how it's going to
be we get to see that resolution
the dynamic and The Chemistry Between
all the characters including the the
fighting game avatars is just so good
across the board I love this episode
this thing's great
number three
USS Callister
this was the very first episode of Black
Mirror that I ever watched
and boy did it hook me I mean it doesn't
hurt that it's allegorically using Star
Trek because
I like Star Trek so that certainly
doesn't hurt but this exploration of
NPCs within a game of how much
programming goes into them and then like
they're stuck just doing this but also
the theft
of other people's sense of self of their
personhood and just repurposing it for
your own entertainment and amusement and
sadism in some CR in some cases and
again
catharsis
not a lot of black mayor does it this
one has a cathartic ending and boy do I
love it I love the way that this like it
is possible to make fun of geek culture
and a certain kind of obsessive geek
without insulting Geeks
and this does it like it's a fine line
to walk and again Charlie Brooker
actually knows what he's talking about
ah this is just good this is also
probably one of the most quotable
episodes
number two
15 million merits
if someone were to ask me to give them
one episode of Black Mirror to watch to
get an idea of what it is
depending on that person I would either
recommend to them USS Callister or I
would recommend to them this and odds
are for most people I'd recommend this
this is kind of the platonic ideal of
examining the technology the far end The
Logical extreme of the technology that
we already have where does that go where
does that lead and examining the impact
of that on people
and examining the literal running on
treadmills and that's just all you do
to spend fake money on fake
entertainment
and to try and grasp for something real
and to actually connect to Bear your
soul
and have that get monetized
speaking of someone who again makes
their living
on a platform like YouTube
boy
and the performances in this especially
from Daniel kaluya
phenomenal
absolutely phenomenal this has
everything that Black Mirror does and it
has it at perfection
but it's not my number one
if you've been around this channel for a
while not only do you know what number
one is going to be you've known since
the moment this list started
and it's not because it's necessarily
better than 50 million merits
but just because it hits me
harder
and in a nicer place
right in the fields
number one
San Junipero
this is one of the most beautiful love
stories I've ever seen put to film the
acknowledgment
of the limitations
of these two women
that as much as they fit together
they're not perfect neither of them is
that things are messy
and complicated
and things that you've lost and left
behind you still carry with you and they
still hurt
and
the
push and pull of holding on to the
moments you have now when you could have
more
but will it still be good if there's
more will it hurt if you're trying to
hold on to more should you just let it
be fleeting do you embrace it
I love this story
this is wanna I I have a tendency to
complain about love stories and a lot of
things
largely it's because there's a lot of
times when love stories feel superfluous
like they're not contributing
but I do still appreciate good love
stories
and this is one of my favorite
this is one of the best love stories
I've ever seen
brilliant use of setting amazing
performances the music choice this is
brilliant this is amazing San Junipero
is my number one pick
for Black Mirror
that is my list I have no doubt it
differs a lot from other people's
so I want to hear yours or your thoughts
on mine or whatever you feel like
sharing
drop it all down in the comments and
let's talk about it patreon pays the
bills
and enables me to do this as my living
as I mentioned a couple times uh that
this is how I uh
I actually make my living it's so weird
to be talking about a show that delves
into technology when my job is this
dependent on technology ha but in any
case either you can't help me out on
patreon like share subscribe there's
links to other things I do get like you
know the drill
but what I really want you to remember
is you are beautiful
you're valid
if you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
Nama thanks my patreon supporters to
make this possible including Robin Moore
Zubin lipfula to rock the thing that
goes doing in the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Linda Walters Jen t love
Auntie Kate 808 bernabi likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalind Bennett
you can get uh my bad I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]